today we'll be explaining every human
that turned into a titan in the whole
attack on titan series and i bet there
are some characters you didn't know
about let's get started carl fretts
since he was a member of the royal
family he inherited the founding titan
in its full power and use it to create
the walls and wipe out people's memories
tom saver it is unknown from whom he
inherited the beast titan but even after
becoming the titan shifter saver mostly
worked as a researcher because he
thought his titan was useless in combat
in wars scout varus varus was among the
soldiers chosen to help leave high guard
zeke in the titan forest he was also the
one who convinced levi to allow them to
take the wine confiscated from the
marlene ships he was turned into a pure
titan by zeke and was commanded to
attack levi but ended up getting killed
just like every other titan that attacks
levi yamir decades ago she was sent to
paradise island and forcibly turned into
a pure titan years went by and she
encountered young warriors on their way
to walls and attacked them managing to
eat marcel and therefore inheriting jaw
titan power aaron krueger krueger
revealed himself as a titan shifter
after saving grisha from being turned
into a pure titan he inherited the
attack titan and lived a full span of 13
years that all titan shifters have upon
receiving this power miss tiber the
tiger family possessed warhammer titan
power for centuries and passed it down
from one family member to another lara
inherited this power and used it to
fight aaron during the invasion of
marley comrade d comrade d was a former
restorationist who was captured by the
merlin soldiers and turned into a titan
for the crime of treason he is one of
several titans to make their way into
the equipment depot of the military
headquarters in trost as the titan
approaches sasha mikasa ackermann kills
him grisha jaeger grisha inherited the
power of the attack titan from the owl
and was entrusted with the mission to
retrieve the power of the founding titan
from within the walls he successfully
did so and inherited the power of the
founding titan as well although his
appearance didn't change yamir fritz
after being chased by the hunters she
fell down into a pool of liquid inside a
large tree there a mysterious creature
fused with her and turned her into a
titan she became the first ever founding
titan and therefore the strongest titan
ever porco galliard after retreating to
marley ymir volunteered to pass on her
titan porco ater and inherited the jaw
titan which he used to help marley fight
the wars ymir's worshipper this woman
was the member of the cult that
worshipped yamir fritz the cult members
were eventually arrested by marley and
she was turned into a pure titan her
titan form was shown in the ova episode
titled isles notebook she was the first
pure titan shown to speak words with
meaning and also display some emotions
yuri reese since he was a member of the
royal family yuri eventually inherited
the founding titan from his father he
only used it a few times like when he
captured kenny ackerman while being half
transformed other than that we don't
know much about him frida reese frieda
volunteered to be yuri's successor and
injected herself with the titan serum
and ate her uncle in order to obtain the
founding titan she was actually the last
pure founding titan before it was merged
with the attack titan after she was
defeated and killed by grisha yeager mr
springer and mrs springer mr springer
was one of the victims gasped by
merlin's soldiers before being turned
into a titan by zeke yeager mr
springer's titan is eventually killed by
the survey corps at some point during
the week before wall rose is declared
titan free miss springer was also turned
into a pure titan by zeke and was left
stranded on top of the roof of their
house she was the only titan from rigako
village that was left alive and after
the aldians lost the power of the titans
miss springer was returned to human form
nile dock zeke yeager transformed nile
into a titan with his scream when the
marlayan military launched a surprise
attack on shigan china as the titan nile
chases the blouse family before
cornering one of them within an alley as
nile lunges forward to attack he is shot
several times and killed by an
anti-titan rifle wielded by gabby
comrade c the same as comrade d comrade
c is also one of the restorationists who
worked with grisha and was captured by
marley's police he was later transformed
into a pure titan and sent towards the
walls the community named him santa
titan and he was actually the one who
ate aaron in season one just imagine if
he chewed him properly he would have
become the new main character armin
arlert armin sacrificed himself in order
for aaron to catch bertolt off guard and
cut him out of his titan nape afterward
he was subject to a dilemma for captain
levi who had a chance to save either him
or commander irwin levi decided that
armin should be saved and injected him
with the serum therefore turning him
into a titan he then ate burdolts and
inherited the colossal titan which he
used to wipe out the entire merlion
fleet later on dina frets dina was
caught committing treason against marley
and was turned into the abnormal titan
the smiling titan after the colossus
titan breaches shiganchina district dina
was one of the many pure titans that
entered the city she came across carla
yeager who was trapped into the debris
of their house and devoured her falco
grice falco has three different titan
forms and each one is very unique
firstly he was transformed into a pure
titan when zeke screamed and shiganshu
in a district after that he ate porco
galliard and therefore inherited his jaw
titan form which he used to help
warriors in the battle and harbor and
finally his most interesting form is the
bird-like jaw titan he used this form to
help the warriors and the survey corps
fight against aaron's founding titan dot
pixas sometime after ingesting zeke's
spinal fluid dot pixis was transformed
into a pure titan during the merlion
surprise attack pixas's pure titan is
spotted by arman who expresses gratitude
for pixis's guidance as he fires a
thunderspear which brings an end to the
former commander rod reese as the only
surviving member of his family rod
decided to persuade his daughter
hystoria into devouring aaron into
becoming the next founding titan but
after she refuses to do so he took titan
serum by himself and became the largest
abnormal titan in existence way larger
than even a colossal titan zeke jaeger
zeke yeager was forced into becoming a
warrior by his parents and later on
proved himself to be good enough to
inherit the beast titan he inherited
titan powers from his father figure tom
saver and in combination with his royal
blood he became extremely powerful jean
connie and gabby gene kersting connie
springer and gabby braun were very
fortunate to be among the rest of the
eldian people who escaped fort slava
they were previously battling aaron's
founding titan and after escaping they
saw that the centipede survived the
explosion and started emitting smoke all
of the aliens in fort slava were
transformed into pure tights and
immediately went to protect the
centipede as it attempts to return to
aaron aaron jaeger aaron is the
character with the most different titan
forms in the series first of all he has
his pure titan form which he was
transformed into when grisha injected
him with the serum next up is his attack
titan form this is aaron's standard form
that we're used to seeing in the anime
in season 4 after he ate lara tiber he
changed his appearance yet again and
became the fusion of the warhammer and
the attack titan after initiating the
rumbling he gained the power of the
founding titan from ymir fritz and
therefore transformed once again into a
giant skeleton titan in the final manga
chapters we also got to see his founding
form when he battled armin peak finger
peak finger was part of the warrior unit
that was selected to inherit the powers
of the titans she inherited the kart
titan that she used in the battle of
shigunchina as well as the marley
mid-east war she mastered her titan
abilities very well being able to spend
up to two months in her titan form
without food or water marcel galliard
marcel galliard was one of the four
warriors who was sent to paradise island
on a mission to steal the founding titan
he inherited the jaw titan from an
unknown source and was very skillful in
using it unfortunately we didn't get to
see more of marcel as he was killed very
early by yamir centipede the centipede
which is also known as the source of all
living matter is the being that granted
yamir fritz the power of the titans
almost 2 000 years ago it was the source
of both the powers of the titans and the
abilities of the founding titan it is
basically the strongest thing in the
entire world as it can give any person
power of the founding titan reiner braun
reiner inherited the armor titan at a
very young age and became one of the
most important titan shifters in the
whole series he was also very good at
using his titan as he was the one who
breached the gates of walmaria annie
leonhart annie leonhart was physically
the strongest and most skillful warrior
in the entire warrior unit she inherited
the female titan and in combination with
her skill set she managed to easily
overpower aaron many times as well as
wipe out many of the senior cervicorps
members in her titan form bertolt hoover
bertolt was the warrior who inherited
the most powerful titans out of them all
the colossal titan with his titan form
bertolt destroyed the gates of walmaria
with a single kick ending the hundred
year lasting piece his titan possessed
some of the most powerful
characteristics in the entire aot world
such as destructive explosions that
could wipe out entire cities click on
this video where we covered 40 small
details he missed an attack on titan go
on click it